[Music]
welcome to noob gaming Network in this
video I'll show how to complete time
square power relay on legendary
difficulty solo I'm doing this on
console with a standard controller and
I've particularly average aim on a good
day if you follow what I do here I
believe anyone regardless of skill
should be able to complete this mission
of the three legendary missions this one
is the easiest attention needs to be put
more into remembering where and win the
NPC spawn so rather than having to be
reactive it's more about being prepared
before we start you want to be using a
skill power build and a sniper here I'm
using a high skill power fire Chryst and
technicians build I'll leave a link in
the description I've broken this mission
down into four parts
number one the beginning number two
stairway to street number three balcony
waves number four boss fight
for this first part you want to have the
fire turret and cluster seeker mine
equipped the top of these stairs is
where you going to hold as the first few
waves will push towards you place your
turret somewhere on the handrails to
slow down the rushes
if you're feeling a bit pushed don't
hesitate and running outside to take
some cover and re-establish your defense
use your si combines to help find any
hidden enemies and clear out the
remainder of the NPCs
[Music]
when you're satisfied that there isn't
any more coming head down the stairs to
the left there's usually a couple of
snipers use your sniper or secant lines
to clear the matter
for the end of this part you can head
towards a room on the left where you're
being directed to turn off the power
before you run and hang back a bit
there'll be a shielded heavy that will
need to be taken out first
[Music]
once the power has been turned off you
can head towards the stairway that'll
take you up to the street
much like the first part you'll be
setting up the defensive position on
these steers as a few waves of enemies
will be rushing towards you use your
turret to slow them and your seekers to
hunt them down
occasionally you'll need to trigger off
the next wave by running up towards the
top of the stairs just keep an eye on
your mini-map as often you'll think
they're cleared but there'll be one guy
just hiding out stopping Nick's wave
from spawning as long as you're prepared
you can just fall back and have your
skills do the work
once the waves are cleared head to the
top of the stairs and take out four
single sniper on the left after that run
towards the balcony further down the
road to the right
ignoring the NPC's in the middle of the
street weren't straight up the stairs
this balcony is where you'll be spending
a large amount of time for the rest of
the mission so get comfy this part can
take a while but patience and
understanding when the NPCs will spawn
is the key
after the first couple of waves you'll
be tasked with taking this case towards
the end of the street you need to
transport this bit by bit keeping a
close eye on your mini-map as soon as
you see enemies appear drop it and
sprint back to the balcony about now
you'll want to change out your flame
turret for a healing station some of the
enemies will now start firing sticky
bombs and seeker mines at you with the
right shot they'll drop you on one hurt
so you want the station to keep you heal
up and revive you if necessary in this
example I've changed to a reclaim build
to get the best out of the healing
station keep inching the case closer to
the fuse box at the end of the street
once this is done you'll have another
wave of enemies this time with a few
snipers
you can either snipe them back or move a
little closer to have your secret mines
take them out
once you've taken out the first two
you'll need to move further down the
road to deal with the remaining two at
the back
after they did run back to the balcony
and take care of the last wave of
enemies before the boss wave
you'll know when X the boss wave because
you'll see a number of purple NPCs
hovering just out of range down the
street
this part isn't actually too hard once
you know what you're doing there will be
two bosses a sniper and a heavy and a
bunch of purpose sitting out of range
you can easily take out the Purple's and
the sniper boss first
don't even bother shooting it the heavy
for now just leave them until the end
the only way you can take down this boss
is to shoot the redhead Fox on his back
the trouble is is quite hard to get him
to turn around when you're playing solo
the easiest way I find is to change over
to ear bursts Iike mines and keep
setting them on fire the flame turret
works too but he'll keep running out of
range
[Music]
if you keep doing this and chipping away
at his hitbox he should drop pretty
quick in this example I was having an
absolute nightmare my aim just wasn't on
point
if you found this useful and you'd like
me to release a video on the other two
legendary missions let me know in the
comments below otherwise thanks for
watching and I'd like to take this
opportunity to thank everyone for the
amazing feedback I've been receiving
lately it means a lot at the end of the
day this is just a hobby for me but it's
really awesome to see that others are
appreciating and finding the stuff
useful so thank you again and see you in
the next video
[Music]